depuis sa création en 1990 l'opération
pièces jaunes a permis de financer 116
projets à l'hôpital necker est
spécialisé dans la pédiatrie à paris
dont l'équipement en informatique du
centre scolaire installée dans
l'établissement hospitalier
mallory ahounou zidène berkous encore
une visite pour la petite laura habitué
aux défilés des blouses blanches
mais cette fois c'est une institutrice
qui vient à son chevet en laurent
legrand 150-160 laura est atteinte de
mucoviscidose
il est trimestre elle passe trois
semaines à l'hôpital dans une chambre
isolée dans ces moments-là l'école lui
manque
laurent est réceptive elle ne demande
que ça si je pouvais lui garde toute la
journée je serais content quand il ya
sévi
oui ok pour les enfants qui peuvent se
déplacer
rendez-vous en classe le centre scolaire
de l'hôpital necker accueille chaque
année plus de 1600 enfants de 3 à 18 ans
un lieu d'étude mais aussi de rencontres
on n'est plus entre entre malades et
soignants
donc je crois que plus cool tiens ça
change
les 23 enseignants du centre deviennent
presque des professeurs particuliers le
temps de l'hospitalisation de plus grâce
à l'informatique financées par les
pièces jaunes
les enfants restent en contact avec
leurs établissements scolaires de quoi
rassurer les parents
découvre que l'école existe à l'hôpital
ils sont quand même très content donc on
demande souvent même aux parents ce qui
paraît étonnant en consultation quand
l'enfant va venir en hospitalisation
d'amener son cartable et ses affaires
scolaires un réflexe qui peut permettre
de sauver une année scolaire cet après
midi par exemple un élève de première
passe en val de france est à l'hôpital